bonjour philippe martinez merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin et de nous
rejoindre vous êtes secrétaire général
de la cgt on a beaucoup de sujets à voir
avec vous ce matin on étend son pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par jefferson des
sports de sud ouest on a commencé
aujourd'hui à faire seul
jour et pertinents on commence par là
cette annonce hier de l'annnonce de jean
castex était hier soir au 20h de tf1 il
a donc annoncé un blocage du prix du gaz
jusqu'au mois d'avril pour faire face à
la hausse du prix du gaz et une
réduction du montant de la taxe sur
l'électricité pour amoindrir cette fois
cette hausse est ce que vous saluer la
réactivité du gouvernement sur ces
sujets la réactivité vous êtes bien
gentil c'est il était temps qu'on
réagisse et qu'il réagisse parce que
nous faisons des propositions depuis un
petit moment premièrement le l'énergie
va continuer à augmenter un même site
est hausse est limité il va continuer à
augmenter les deux gaz électricité donc
c'est un ça reste un problème et puis il
ya d'autres mesures à prendre par
exemple
l'état a gagné beaucoup d'argent avec la
hausse de l'énergie par le biais de la
tva et d'autres taxes comment on remet
ça on regarde ça nous nous proposons que
c'était la baisse c'est un produit de
première nécessité il faudra qu'elle
passe à 5,5 et demi pour cent
il a le droit de dire ce qu'il veut
l'état gagné beaucoup d'argent avec la
tva et sur d'autres produits et nous
nous proposons que sur l'ensemble des
produits de première nécessité cette tva
soit 17 donc l'énergie précis mais
principalement l'énergie il ya d'autres
choses mais l'énergie est un besoin
essentiel donc il faut baisser la laddh
la deuxième chose c'est que il a oublié
de parler que angie qu'un des opérateurs
essentiel du gaz a réalisé près de 3
milliards de bénéfices sur les six
premiers mois de l'année donc angie
profite aussi de ses os et pas pour
petites entreprises qu'est ce qu'on fait
vis-à-vis d'énergie par rapport à ça et
puis je pense qu'il est temps de revenir
à cette question essentielle quand
est-ce qu'on revient un pôle public de
l'énergie il faut que edf gdf avec gdf
qui devenu angie est bien re devienne
propriété à 100% de l'état pour
permettre une meilleure régulation de
l'énergie et les prix de l'énergie en
tout cas c'est insuffisant philippe
martinez souvenir ce matin ces mesures
annoncées par jean castex parce que il
ya eu une hausse de 12% en gaz / début
octobre avant cette année depuis
depuis quelques années c'est près de 70%
voire la hausse et 55 et janvier depuis
le début de l'année mais si on prend sur
deux ans ça doit avoisiner les 70% là
l'électricité c'est pareil donc il ya
une vraie réflexion à avoir sur
l'ensemble de ces questions mais avec
une entreprise publique électricité et
gaz parce qu'on voit bien que on voit
bien tous les bienfaits de la
concurrence en la matière on nous avait
promis que avec de nombreux opérateurs
tout le monde est gagnant voyez le
résultat parce que l'objectif de jean
castex r c'était d'aider le pouvoir
d'achat des français et l'a ouvert
également la porte à une nouvelle
revalorisation du chaque énergie déjà y
aura une revalorisation en décembre 200
euros lui dit si ça ne suffit pas on
peut réfléchir à une nouvelle
revalorisation s'avoue salué cette
mesure moi je la seule revalorisation
que j'attends avec la cgt c'est le smic
oui le smic augmente aujourd'hui de
essentiellement par un objet par le
biais d'une opération mécanique c'est
largement insuffisant on peut vous
pousser un peu plus de 10 ans 5 euros
brut par mois 35 euros bora demande un
brin post mais puisqu'un coup de pouce
c'est un coût d'un coup de pied pour que
ça monte oui j'étais dans une ferme en
deux juste qu'on pense que saddam en
2000 euros des millions en 2001 2000
euros de base alors ça peut être
progressif mais fois les rapidement vers
les deux me retrouvais j'étais dans une
entreprise de l'agroalimentaire tout le
monde parle des branches
qui serait mal payé et c'est à juste
titre les essentiels de cette perle de
covile et bien pas c'est une entreprise
les salariés sont en grève depuis 17
jours
non seulement ils ont travaillé pendant
la corrida mais aujourd'hui par
l'entreprise leur à baisser leurs
salaires par un accord de compétitivité
ils ont perdu pratiquement 500 euros par
mois eh bien avec 25 ans d'ancienneté
ils ont un salaire de base de 1600 euros
aujourd'hui le smic passe à 1588 euros
ils sont 12 euros d'au dessus du smic ça
c'est à changer et au lieu de dire il
faut discuter dans les branches eh bien
il faut agir pour le pas par le biais du
smic pour que automatiquement parce que
vous le savez certainement même si le
smic augmente il n'y a pas automaticité
des des salaires dans les branches et
bien il faut une loi qui dise quand le
smic augmente automatiquement le salaire
doit évoluer dans les branches voilà un
cas concrets sur lesquels le
gouvernement peut agir donc philippe
artières sur le pouvoir d'achat
globalement le pool gouvernement n'est
pas au rendez vous alors ce sera un des
thèmes de la présidentielle mais est ce
que vous dites premièrement il faut pas
parler uniquement de pouvoir d'achat il
faut parler salaire parce que
oui typiquement d'aider des primes des
chèques etc c'est une mesure ponctuelle
mais pas pérenne la seule mesure pérenne
c'est l'augmentation des salaires dont
il faut parler des salaires les
retraités sont mobilisation aujourd'hui
et 6 pour revaloriser les pensions
géré directement sur le salaire plus que
sur la notion de pouvoir d'achat parce
que j'entendais mesure qui consisterait
à dire
faut augmenter les salaires en
supprimant les cotisations sociales
c'est-à-dire qu'on vous donne d'une main
ce qu'on vous a piqué dans l'autre et
sur les retraités puisque effectivement
ils se mobilisent aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs villes de france pour une
revalorisation de leurs pensions qu'est
ce que vous attendez précisément je me
revalorisation de combien de une
revalorisation des pensions là aussi il
faut il ne faut plus qu aucune pension
soit en dessous du smic et vous le savez
il ya de plus en plus de retraités
pauvres des pensions
de retraite qui avoisine les 900 voire
en dessous euros on peut pas vivre avec
ça pour vous c'est en dessous du smic
parce que le gouvernement donc c'est pas
moi c'est la réalité des pensions vous
demandez une des pensions le colosse
aucune pension en dessous des normes
dans sa réforme des retraites le
gouvernement aussi le parler d'une
minimum de pension de retraite de 1000
euros ça il faut que ça soit mis en
oeuvre tout de suite pour vous il faut
la mesure que nous demandons c'est qu'il
n'y ait plus aucune pension de retraite
en dessous du smic mille euros c'est
largement les médias qu'il faut
commencer à mettre en oeuvre la réforme
des retraites entre les mesures de la
réforme des retraites dont pas une
mesure on va parler du reste pris une
mesure celle est-ce qu'il faut la mettre
en place je me suis fait la mettre en
place dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale je ris je vous le redis oui bien
sûr mais pas une pension en dessous du
smic ne s'est pas 1000 euros même le son
bien il a même le smic actuelle ne s'est
pas mis leur au
sujet des retraites par noria de mantoue
qu'à sion continue cela vous a pas
échappé leur fils dans son interview
challenges et ça m'a proposé de
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 65 66 67 ans on imagine que ça vous a
fait bondir philippe martin est
scandaleux c'est scandaleux c'est
scandaleux que les hommes politiques et
les femmes politiques un certain nombre
veulent travailler c'est déjà le cas et
travaillent parfois jusqu'à 80 ans ça
les regarde mais vous imaginez moi je
vois les aides à domicile les
infirmières
les salariés des ehpad ils vont être
aussi âgé que les résidents ceux qui ont
des métiers pénibles il y en a beaucoup
et la crise dako vide la révéler je
pense aux éboueurs par exemple vous
imaginer travailler jusqu'à 67 ans et
enfin y avait quand même une prise en
compte de la pénibilité non c'est parce
que
vous me parlez d'edouard philippe il a
dit retraite à 67 ans il habite où il
habite où il a dit il dit hier nous
préférons continuer à danser au dessus
du volcan que de prendre des mesures
drastiques et parfois maire vous avez
l'impression
j'ai apprécié qu'il habite pas dans la
mer sur sur la même planète sur moi ni
dans le même pays
et puis la deuxième question c'est
comment on va lutter contre le chômage
en maintenant plus longtemps en
maintenant plus longtemps 10 des
salariés au boulot
alors qu'il ya huit millions de
demandeurs d'emploi quand on réduit
l'âge de la retraite ça libère du
travail pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
puis il ya le troisième problème c'est
que là aussi nie les réalités pourtant
il a été premier ministre et j'ai eu
l'occasion de lui dire mon entreprise
c'est que dans majorité des salariés ne
vont pas jusqu'à l'âge de la retraite
pour diverses raisons mais une
principale c'est que les entreprises les
licenciés avant soit par des plans dits
de départs volontaires donc il ya
pourquoi on maintient pas en activité
déjà ses salariés jusqu'à 60 ans ça fait
des cotisations sociales et ça pose le
problème différemment mais ça veut dire
que pour vous il ne faut rien faire
concernant le régime des retraites
on en a parlé pendant un an et demi je
sais que ça fait presque deux ans mais
faut pas avoir la mémoire courte si fort
et fort info faut changer les choses
faut abaisser l'âge de la retraite pour
libérer du travail notamment aux jeunes
qui n'en n'ont pas et puis il faut
revoir le système d'exonération de
cotisations notre système il est
solidaire parce qu'il ya des cotisations
parce qu'il ya des cotisations sociales
pour les salariés comme pour les
employant merci ça va pas aucun risque
si on n'augmente pas l'âge de départ à
la retraite et donc si on cotise pas
plus longtemps on met justement en péril
les pensions des retraités puisqu'on est
dans un centre la répartition des
retraités qui manifestent aujourd'hui
pourraient trouver leur ai dit qu'on a
des propositions puisque je vous dis il
faut reprendre il faut ré ouvrir le
robinet des cotisations on ferme le
robinet des cotisations par des tas
d'exonérations pourquoi les salaires
sont bas en france parce qu'urs les
employeurs ne paye plus aucune
cotisation pour les salariés qui sont
payés jusqu'à 1,6 fois le smic ça
maintient les salaires parce que ça
maintient les salaires au plus bas donc
il faut ré ouvert le robinet des
cotisations on a un système solidaire on
mène on en a été fier pendant la commune
les berthevinoises case soit on le
renforce comme vous voyez cette
proposition d'edouard philippe à ce que
vous craignez que la préco vide ce soit
un retour non d'avant et qu'on revienne
sur
éthique libérale avec jetons c'est déjà
le cas c'est déjà le cas donc on a
tourné la page de la solidarité de la
grille et terminer ma gommer tout ce
qu'on a dit pendant ces 1 an et demi les
deuxièmes lignes ils sont toujours mal
payés je vous ai cité un exemple
on continue à fermer des services et des
lits dans les hôpitaux il ya eu une
enquête très sérieuse qui l'a révélé
les aides à domicile et une petite
revalorisation mais pas pour tout le
monde elles sont essentielles elles sont
essentielles il faut prendre en compte
la diversité de leurs problèmes c'est la
demande était refermée mais largement et
vous savez que les 12es site et angie
mais les 37 parmi les 40 plus grandes
entreprises françaises ont gagné on
dégager 57 milliards de bénéfices à
qu'il profite de cela ses bénéfices aux
actionnaires points on va parler de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage elle
entre en vigueur aujourd'hui donc ça son
volet le plus contesté en plus celui du
calcul des indemnisations chômage c'est
un échec pour vous ce matin cette entrée
en vigueur ah non c'est la démonstration
que le gouvernement qui se dit ouvert à
la discussion à la concertation quand
toutes les organisations syndicales de
ce pays sont contre une réforme c'est
suffisamment rare pour être souligné qu'
il y ait unanimité des organisations
syndicales et bien faut retirer le
projet c'est un projet injuste c'est
scandaleux même de dire que c'est de la
faute aux chômeurs s'ils sont au chômage
ça c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux et
il ya des tas de personnes qui sait
qu'il ya trois millions de chômeurs qui
ne touchent rien dire qu'en réduisant
leur leurs revenus au chômage ils vont
trouver du boulot ceux qui gagnent rien
ils devraient tous avoir du boulot et on
va écouter justement ce qu'on disait
jean castex air de cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage puisqu'il en a parlé
au 20h de terre y avait une réforme
d'assurance chômage
et qui avaient été décidés il ya eu la
crise le chômage a fortement augmenté
nous l'avons suspendue là la situation
est totalement différente
grâce aux efforts de nos concitoyens
grâce aux mesures aussi prises par le
gouvernement la croissance économique
est la plus forte des pays de la zone
euro le chômage a fortement diminué il a
déjà retrouvé son niveau d'avant crise
aujourd'hui le problème auquel le chef
du gouvernement que je suis se trouvent
confrontées ces deux pour voir les très
nombreux emplois que l'économie crée
c'est c'est une petite musique une
petite rengaine qui est absolument là
aussi insupportable j'ai entendu que la
ministre avait trouvé en la mise du
travail en deux jours on était passé de
trois semaines trois cent mille emplois
non pourvus à un million je sais pas
d'où elles sortent ces chiffres nous le
constat que nous faisons là combien pour
vous aider en plaindre qu'on dépasse 15
a aujourd'hui des engueulades entre
250000 et 310 encore faut vérifier parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de d'offrir
d'emplois qui sont qui sont des
prévisions d'emploi et quand vous
l'expliqué cette pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans certains secteurs
premièrement je vous je continuais à une
partie des 250 milles à 320 points c'est
une prévision se taire quand on dit ben
il va y avoir des départs en retraite il
faut se dit donc c'est pas tout à fait
des emplois non pourvus aujourd'hui
comment l'expliquer premièrement bah
c'est pas moi qu'ils expliquent ces
ministère du travail attractivité des
métiers c'est une enquête officielle
rémunération faible rénumération
conditions de travail exposition
produits dangereux c'est une enquête du
ministère du travail et donc la mise du
travail devrait lire les enquêtes qui
sortent de son ministère et on sait bien
que durant là que vides dia des salariés
qui n'ont pas travaillé sur match
partiel etc qui ne pouvait plus et ont
changé de métier ont changé de métier
bon bah il faut s'intéresser et nous le
proposons depuis plusieurs années sur
l'attractivité des métiers le sens du
travail a de plus en plus de salariés
qui se dit mais à quoi ça sert mon
boulot je vais faire autre chose à quoi
ça sert bon travail ben là on ferme les
yeux on dit c'est de la faute des
chômeurs s'ils sont au chômage ce combat
est terminé pour vous philippe martineau
fin de la saison puisqu'elle rentrons
vigueur non pas du tout le goudron va
faire on continue à les recours qu'on
avait fait à la précédente réforme le
gouvernement essayait de de de nous
avoir encore le 2 vous savez que le
décret sorti here donc on peut pas
porter l'affairé devant le conseil
d'état si on n'a pas lecture du décret
donc on l'a eue hier on a travaillé on
va faire un recours est là aussi tous
les syndicats
tous les syndicats tous les syndicats
vont faire un recours
est organisée je sais pas s'il sera
commun de tous en tout cas chaque
organisation syndicale va contester
j'insiste là dessus on parle beaucoup de
dialogues on parle beaucoup des écoutes
mais vous et la réalité c'est quand tout
le monde est contre on dit bon on fait
quand même moi je m'interroge sur la
volonté du gouvernement de d'écouter les
syndicats mais plus globalement les
français castex philips c'est le même
combat même au gouvernement même c'est
là c'est la continuité c'est la
continuité même si
le monsieur castex a eu à gérer
la cosi dans sa phase la plus forte mais
c'est la continuité c'est culpabiliser
les salariés culpabiliser les chômeurs
culpabiliser le monde du travail en
général les retraités et puis d'épargné
c'est le cas de le dire le mot est bien
choisi ce qui profite de cette crise
pour s'en mettre plein les poches juste
une petite précision ce recours avait
déjà coûté je sais pas moi le
spécialiste du juridique à la cgt mais
on va dire on a on a huit jours je crois
pour le déposer donc
on vous préviendra faut qu'on était là
la question de jefferson puisqu'on
arrive au bout maintenant et même un
conte comment vous le qualifiez vous en
matière de dialogue social ah bah c'est
cause toujours tu m'intéresses on peut
résumer ça comme ça c'est c c'est
beaucoup de communication beaucoup d'
écoute vous savez le grand débat et
syndicats or les syndicats sont pas
importants quand il ennuie le
gouvernement puissant important quand il
ya une crise d gilet jaune il faut
discuter il faut trouver des solutions
c'est beaucoup de communication et puis
une plante qu'on vient vous chercher
quand il a besoin oui bien sûr ressenti
sur d'opportunisme la communication
héééé en fait tout ce qui n'est tout
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec lui
ne m'intéresse pas c'est j'ai raison
tout seul la vie nous montrent qu' il ya
beaucoup de contestations il y aura une
journée d'action le 5 octobre de
nouveaux il ya beaucoup de problèmes
dans ce pays je crois que le
qualificatif où l'expression président
des riches va sûrement évoluer le cours
du quinquennat maintenant c'est le
président des très très riche comment
vous entendez vous peser dans cette
campagne présidentielle quels rôles
entend jouer la cgt est ce que par
exemple vous allez recevoir les
candidats je pense pas qu'on va les
recevoir nous nous on a des propositions
de premièrement je trouve que tout le
débat un peu politiciens sûr qu'il va
être candidat c'est moi le meilleur et
c'est alors que pour une élection qui
aura lieu dans dix mois alors que les
problèmes ils sont sept manches 6-7 mais
je vois pas le temps passer
on entend tellement
il commet s'occupe des préoccupations
des français aujourd'hui dans vos moi
dans mes discussions vous ce site et des
deux mois je fais beaucoup de
déplacements on parle pas de la
présidentielle on parle de la fin du
mois du chômage l'éducation de la
culture et ses septièmes ils sont passés
présents ou représentés
je me félicite que par exemple la
question des salaires reviennent sur le
dessus de la pile
mais il faut que les salariés y pèse le
monde du travail des citoyens justement
vous faire ensemble
cette journée dans la journée du 5
octobre par exemple c'est pour dire
voilà les préoccupations
aujourd'hui qui doivent être traités
aujourd'hui est évidemment avec des
solutions qui évolue et la campagne
présidentielle c'est l'occasion d'y
aller questions environnementales parce
que nous pensons que l'environnement et
le social ça doit être porté ensemble
voilà les sujets qui préoccupent les
français les jeunes les moins jeunes
tout question de la question des
salaires ya déjà une candidate qui a
proposé de doubler le salaire des
enseignants une anne hidalgo ça va dans
le bon sens c'est quelque chose que vous
attendez
c'est qu'il n'y a pas que le salaire des
enseignants et qu'il faut qu'il faut
doubler les le aujourd'hui entre en
vigueur le le cdur de la santé c'est
insuffisant j'ai parlé des aides à
domicile il ya des mesures mais c'est
des mesurettes et les deuxièmes il faut
citer c'est qu'il ya pratiquement 70%
des des salaires de base dans les
branches qui démarre en dessous du smic
voilà des questions essentielles et puis
avec questions d'emploi on porte des
projets industriels on a plein de
projets la question fait maintient sur
les thèmes de cette campagne vous nous
dites les thèmes sociaux les thèmes du
pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème croque
les français mais ils ont du mal à
s'imposer comment vous l'expliquez est
ce que c'est parce que par exemple eric
zemmour pour ne pas le citer c'est lui
qui réussit à imposer ses thèmes dans
cette campagne aussi avec lui
mais beaucoup de candidats ou de futurs
candidats ou de potentiels candidats
essaient de détourner les sujets de
préoccupation ce qu'ont les sujets
sociaux les sujets emplois vers d'autres
sujets des ans des vieilles rengaines
culpabilisation des immigrés les
questions de sécurité c'est pas des
petits problèmes enfin c'est pas les
problèmes qu'on rencontre le plus haut
moi je suis assez surpris d'ailleurs que
sur les questions d'immigration
reviennent pas sur ce qui se passe au
royaume uni on a viré les immigrés vous
avez vu les queue aux stations d'essence
l'immigration c'est essentiel pour un
pays un dernier mot sur sur eric zemmour
comment vous et qualifiez vous est ce
qui vous inquiète aujourd'hui on parle
c'est un mois je ne comprends pas qu'on
lui fasse autant de publicité alors
qu'il a été condamné pour
racisme mais voilà c'est la réalité
peut-être
c'est un raciste c'est un il refait
l'histoire quand on dit pettinger et des
juifs enfin c'est assez c'est proprement
scandaleux sauf que c'est quelqu'un
qu'on fait monter en avant je ne sais
pas enfin je sais à peu près pourquoi
bat pour éviter des sujets dont on a
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup
ce matin un nouveau coup de tonnerre
s'étalait cheveux votre journal
[Musique]